la russie est elle sur le point
d'attaquer l'ukraine longtemps
hypothétique ce scénario devient
désormais plausible si l'on en croit
américains et britanniques ils
rappellent leurs diplomates et leurs
familles une réaction jugée pour l'heure
alarmiste par l'union européenne
bruxelles attend des preuves plus
concrètes prématuré et excessif estiment
de leur côté les autorités ukrainiennes
inquiète d'être ainsi livrés à leur sort
johanna ces trucs
la réunion était déjà inscrite à
l'agenda les ministres européens des
affaires étrangères avait rendez vous ce
lundi à bruxelles pour discuter du
conflit qui oppose kiev à moscou
je ne pense pas qu'il faille dramatiser
dans la mesure où les négociations se
poursuivent et c'est bien le cas je ne
pense pas que nous devions laisser
l'ukraine t partir
le secrétaire d'état américain blinken
nous expliquera les raisons de cette
année
car quelques heures avant la réunion la
donne a changé les etats-unis ont
annoncé l'évacuation des familles de
leurs diplomates en ukraine ils
redoutent de voir moscou y imposer un
dirigeant prorusse
le royaume uni à l'origine de ces
accusations a rapidement suivi le
mouvement pour le premier ministre boris
johnson une invasion de l'ukraine par la
russie serait à la fois désastreuse
douloureuse violente et sanglante de son
côté l'union européenne préfèrent
renforcer son soutien financier pour
aider kiev à se défendre et la france
conseille à ses ressortissants de
reporter leurs voyages non essentiels
en parallèle les pays de l'otan ont
envoyé des renforts militaires prêts à
intervenir en cas d' attaque car des
milliers de soldats russes sont postés
depuis plusieurs semaines à la frontière
avec l'ukraine une situation qui n'est
pas sans rappeler celle de 2014 lorsque
moscou s'étaient emparés de la péninsule
de crimée